I had somebody asked me if I caught the
PTSD like like the flu that I what if i
catched the PTSD there's no way that the
military has females on the frontline
there is no way that you as small as you
are were able to shoot a 50 Cal no I did
every day all day and was pretty good at
it too when I'm wearing my little pink
USMC veteran hat and someone says so how
did you serve I said well I was a Marine
oh wow you don't look like a Marine a
veteran is someone who served a veteran
looks like me humor is one way of just
coping with stress it's a release I got
this backpack and inside this this
backpack a couple pairs of t-shirts
couple a pair of shorts couple pairs
underwear some socks which luckily now
last me twice as long as you folks it's
okay to laugh if the one-legged dude is
telling the one-legged jokes shaven one
eyebrow off what all the soldiers asleep
and he wakes up only have one eyebrow
that was human if you can laugh about
things then you can take away some of
the seriousness that's there there is a
such thing as invisible wounds they
don't see me as a disabled veteran
because I have all my limbs traumatic
brain injury post-traumatic stress
whatever that might be and you can't see
them they look fully functioning but
they're severely injured post-traumatic
stress is an isolator
post-traumatic stress it's kind of
stigmatized it isn't something that just
happens in war it's something that
happens when you get put in an extreme
circumstance it's a human experience the
biggest thing that people think is that
we are all angry that we're always mad
about something or that you can't ask us
a question because we'll freak out you
end up living with that for a long time
that that survivor's guilt what if what
if I've just been paying a little bit
closer attention could I have seen
something
to you and they shake your hand I think
they thank you for your service and they
call you a hero and you're like heroes
don't get people killed
when I started talking to the Wounded
Warrior Project if I say my life fell
apart they kind of like gave me like the
plans to figure out so I could put it
back together
21 22 veterans a day committing suicide
is just too much for me and nobody
should have to lose their life from war
after they've come home from war there's
a lot of people that feel alone I need
to step up and make other people not
feel alone
[Music]